AND THEN
YOU READ ABOUT!
TO G WAS NEARLY THIS
GAME.
>> John: HERE COMES KAPRIZOV
LOST THE HANDLE,HEN BARBASHEV,
POINTS IN22, FIALA.
AS
TRYING TO GO WIDE ON ICING
CALL AGAINST THE WILD.
>> Darren: WELL, DAVID PERRON
AND I THINK HE HAD TWO SHIFTS
AFTER THAT 2 ON 1.
>> Darren: YEAH AND IT LOOKED
LIKE MacKENZIE MacEACHERN WAS
LOOKING TO HIS ren: THEY'VE DON
HUSSO AND BACK IN.
AND
DOES HIS JOB THERE ON DUHAIME,
STRIPS THE PUCK RIGHT THERE AND,
OHOH IT
THERE.
AND BRODIN DUMPS THAT ARE BELOW
YOU LIKE NASHVILLE AND LIKE
DALLAS, YOU'VE GOT TO
THAT SHOT GOES BLUES HAVE WON 5.
ANND THE BOYS GOT HIM
THE PUCK FOR HIS FIRST GOAL AS A
MINNESOTA WILD.
AND,  BY HUSSO.
>> John: BY THE SAVE BY TALBOT
TARASENKO.
HE'S HAD HIS ONE-TIMER AND A ZO
SPARKATIVE MAKES ITWITNESS, PAS
FRONT. GREAT HANDS HE'S GOT
RIGHTOR THE BLUES TO
BUCHNEVICH, TRYING TO CUT TO THE
INSIDE.
AND NOW BUCHNEVICH RN, HE IS A
HE?
>> Darren: YE
AND NOW BRODIN BACK IN HIS OWN
ZONE.
>> Darren: TELL YOU BACK-CHECK
ERIKSSON EK.
>> John: DUMPED AROUND.
SEE IF THEY CAN TONIGHT AGAINST
MINNESOTA BUT REGARDLESS WHAT  .
>> John: HERE COMES ROBERT